bruno daroux bonjour c'est donc un
embargo progressif qui a été conclu la
nuit dernière avec un aménagement pour
la hongrie la slovaquie la république
tchèque très des personnes très
dépendantes ans aujourd'hui oui ce sont
trois pays qui sont situés en europe
centrale qui sont très enclavées qui
n'ont pas d'accès sur la mer et qui sont
donc très dépendante de l'oléoduc
droujba qui vient de la russie qui
traverse la biélorussie et qui va
directement alimenter ces trois pays
alors c'était surtout viktor orban le le
premier ministre hongrois qui faisait
blocage en expliquant que son pays était
très dépendants du pétrole russe à
hauteur donc de deux tiers de ses
besoins
ça semblait mal parti et puis comme
souvent dans la saga bruxelloise on
discute jusque tard dans la nuit et
finalement vers une heure du matin on
trouve un compromis qui stipule donc
effectivement qu'à terme ce sont 90 %
des importations de pétrole en
provenance de la russie qui seront
arrêtés
et en attendant et bien la hongrie et la
république tchèque et la slovaquie ils
vont pouvoir continuer à recevoir par
oléoducs sont les livraisons par voie
maritime qui seront stoppés
progressivement quand même alors ça va
priver la russie quand même de recettes
importantes
l'an dernier la russie a tiré quand même
110 milliards de dollars de ses
exportations de pétrole ce qu'elle
exporte vers l'europe c'est à peu près
60% de ses exportations globales dont il
60% sur 110 milliards ça fait autour
normalement de 65 66 milliards c'est
quand même une véritable somme est
l'objet des sanctions c'est de priver la
russie 2 milliards de recettes pour
faire qu'il soit plus difficile pour
elle de financer son effort de guerre
donc c'est important c'est un pas
important qui a été fait quand même même
si c'est au prix de ce compromis mais
c'est souvent cas dans l'histoire de
l'union européenne alors après la
question c'est quel va être l'impact sur
les européens est ce que ça veut dire
que ce pétrole plus rare sera plus chers
pour les consommateurs européens
évidemment ça les intéresse ça nous
intéresse directement est ce que les
pays européens ont prévu des des
approvisionnements
alternatives pendant cette durée de
transition en quelque sorte ensuite
est-ce que ça va convaincre vladimir
poutine de stopper la guerre on n'y
croit pas de revenir même dans des
négociations un peu sérieuse sans doute
pas dans l'immédiat et puis est ce que
cette décision difficile sur le pétrole
ouvre la voie à la mer des sanctions
c'est à dire une décision sur le gaz
russe qui représente encore plus de
recettes pour les russes les européens
doivent s'y atteler on verra dans les
prochaines semaines d'autres dossiers
aussi à régler plusieurs grandes
questions qui seront sur la table
aujourd'hui la défense de lieux les
stocks de munitions ou encore la crise
des céréales toujours bloqué en ukraine
à la crise de céréales l'idée c'est
d'essayer de trouver un accord pour que
les plus de 20 millions de tonnes qui
sont actuellement bloqués en ukraine
puisse être exporté avant que le blé ne
pourrisse et puis ça commence à
provoquer une crise alimentaire vraiment
important dans certains pays du proche
orient et en afrique
donc là les européens travaillent sur
deux voies soit trouvée faire en sorte
que les russes et les ukrainiens se
mettre d'accord pour que les bateaux
puissent quitter les ports de la mer
noire et traverser en sécurité
la mer noire est elle une part la la
flotte russe qui est présente de paille
et les mines ukrainiennes dans cette mer
donc ça c'est une première option
l'autre option c'est une exportation de
ce blé par voie terrestre mais là ça
doit passer par le territoire biélorusse
donc il faudrait l'accord du président
biélorusse qui est le plus proche allié
de moscou voyez donc que cette affaire
dont il discute là ne sera sans doute
pas réglé aujourd'hui il ya aussi une
décision qui va sortir de ce sommet
c'est donc une aide directe de 9
milliards d'euros à l'ukraine pour
envisager la reconstruction et puis on
parle europe de la défense avec
effectivement un problème sur les stocks
de munitions donc encore pas mal de
travail sans doute pas de décision
définitive sur ces dossiers dans les
prochaines heures sommet fin de sommet
qu'on va suivre continuez à suivre
aujourd'hui encore merci beaucoup bruno
pour l'éclairer